there's a church in the city of
Bethlehem it was built on the spot where
Christians believe Jesus was born it's
called the Church of the Nativity if you
consult UNESCO List of World Heritage
Sites or ask travel expert Rick Steves
both will tell you that the church is in
Palestine but when a question about the
church's location came up during a round
of Jeopardy in January 2020 built in the
300s ad the Church of the Nativity
what is Palestine know what is Israel
that's in that answer set off something
of an internet firestorm
[Music]
that's because what you call this land
and who controls it is at the center of
a decades-long conflict between Israelis
and Palestinians but more recently there
is also a third group that is becoming
more and more influential here and
throughout the Middle East American
evangelical Christians today evangelical
Christians are one of the most
politically powerful voting blocks in
the United States and in the trump
administration they've been given
unprecedented power they've turned
support for Israel and hostility towards
its enemies into core tenets of
conservative ideology and a big part of
those policies is rooted in how they
interpret the Bible in 2016 more than a
quarter of all u.s. voters identified as
white evangelical Christians one of the
primary differences between evangelicals
and other Christians is their
relationship with the Bible conservative
evangelicals believe that the Bible is
literally true Sarah Posner writes about
religion for a bunch of different
publications many of them believe that
the Bible is sort of this prophetic
roadmap for modern life that events
described and prophesied in the Bible
will it will become true the Bible is
the most historically accurate book ever
penned the Bible is the one book that
dares to predict the future with 100%
accuracy for evangelicals the most
important of the Bible's prophecies is
the second coming when Jesus will return
to earth the Bible doesn't say when this
will happen
but it does say where this is Jerusalem
world history as we know it is going to
end right here Greg Laurie is an
evangelical preacher one of several who
meet regularly to advise President Trump
they are the leaders of mega churches
with tens of thousands of members
and many of them including Greg Laurie
preacher belief called Christian Zionism
the idea that the return of the Jewish
people to Israel is one of a series of
events that will trigger Jesus's second
coming Jesus is telling us that the
rebirth of Israel is a sign of the end
not just a sign it's the super sign
according to this theology God will
reward those who help Israel and punish
those who don't Jesus will be honest
throne and he separates the nations on
what basis how they treated Rover Zion
let's back up after the Holocaust the UN
divided up the then British territory of
Palestine home to more than a million
Arabs into two states giving Jews who
had been persecuted in Europe a homeland
over the next few decades Israel thought
multiple wars with its Arab neighbors
and seized much of the land that had
been originally set aside for
Palestinians evangelical Christians see
that as a fulfillment of Biblical
prophecy it happened exactly as we're
told it was a miraculous act of God ever
since groups like Hamas have been
fighting against the Israelis trying to
win that territory back and the
government of Iran has been one of their
biggest supporters
[Music]
that's part of the reason Iran plays
such an important role in evangelical
beliefs about the present state of the
world and the future according to
Christian Zionism if the US wants to be
on the right side of Biblical prophecy
they need to do everything possible to
protect Israel and punish Iran that also
helps explain why a different Bible
story is also really important to them
the Old Testament story of Esther about
a plot to destroy the Jews of Persia or
modern-day Iran the book of Esther plays
such an important role for Christian
Zionists they've made multiple movies
out of it he has convinced your husband
to destroy all the Jews including Esther
saves the Jews by using her persuasion
with the king evangelicals who are very
wrapped up in this kind of theology
because Persia is modern-day Iran they
sort of contextualized this Bible story
into foreign policies could it be that
that President Trump right now has been
sort of raised for such a time as this
just like Queen Esther to help save the
Jewish people from an Iranian Menace as
a Christian I certainly believe that's
possible I'm confident that the Lord is
at work here Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and vice president Mike Pence
both identify as evangelical Christians
and both have enormous influence over
American foreign policy app Republican
investigation found that pence routed
millions of dollars in foreign aid it
had been earmarked for humanitarian
projects in Iraq diverting it towards
Christian groups in the country when
President Trump approved the drone
strike that killed Iran's top military
commander in January 2020 it was
according to the Washington Post at
Pompeo and Pence's urging when President
Trump moved the US Embassy in Israel
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem the move had
more support from American evangelicals
than American Jews the other news
swirling around the embassies moved to
Jerusalem is what it could signal as
part of Biblical prophecy Donald Trump
recognized history he like King Cyrus
before him fulfilled the bill
prophecy that evangelical support isn't
an accident the Trump administration
courts it after the administration put
out a peace plan that would have given
Israel unprecedented control over
Palestinian land the Christian broadcast
network interviewed Trump's ambassador
to Israel you're talking about opening
up the Bible bring you back to life in
ways that I think your listeners could
not have even have imagined it's an
opportunity for biblical tourism that I
think will grow in in flourish in
profound ways the network's coverage
followed his lead good news in this
proposed peace plan Israel would have
sovereignty over many historical
biblical sites for evangelical
Christians in America the Bible isn't
just a foundational text its prophetic
roadmap that tells the future and shapes
the way they view the present and for an
influential group of them that motivates
their support for a foreign policy that
they see as affirming those prophecies
and a president who depends on their
votes